[Music]
yeah
displays of prowess is something China
is good at the West once hoped this
power could be the broker of Peace but
it has spent the last year quietly
providing Russia with Finance technology
and diplomatic cover the Americans now
believe it's also preparing to sell arms
position ultimately boils down to a
pretty cynical calculation about what is
best for China it does care about its
International reputation but a
relationship with a strong Russia also
provides Commodities a peaceful northern
border and crucially a like-minded Ally
in an increasingly tense standoff with
the West
and it shifts in that standoff that may
be pushing China closer to Putin
of course right there buddy a row over a
spy balloon just the latest low ebb
in fact China's top Diplomat went to
Moscow this week solidifying what the
two leaders once called a No Limits
friendship
but there is caution too Victor Gower
spent his career amongst the top
echelons of China's leadership and just
listened to how he couches the terms of
that friendship Without Limits doesn't
mean there should be no bottom line
there still should be a borderline to
our friendship which does not have an
upper ceiling to it and what should be
the bottom line that is U.N Charter
respecting each other sovereignty and
territorial integrity and whatever
problems or disputes there are you need
to resolve them by peaceful means
reporting of the war is highly sanitized
here America and NATO framed as the
aggressors a useful narrative if China
ever made its own move on Taiwan what it
does next will be watched intently it
could well alter the course of this war
Helena Smith Sky News in Beijing